[Music]
what's going on guys my name is David
Thomas and welcome back to the channel
today we're not going to be doing your
typical boring unboxing video instead
we're gonna dive straight into the a
user review of the Microsoft Surface
laptop - I've had this product for about
seven months now and I can by far say
that it is the best laptop I've owned
however stick around to the end of the
video and you're gonna find out why I'm
gonna tell you not to buy it yet
so straight out of the box you're gonna
notice that the surface laptop too comes
in a very sleek profile design it has
that wedge finish very similar to the
Apple MacBook Air if you compare the
weight of this versus a MacBook Air
you're actually going to find out that
this one is a little bit lighter by
about 50 grams give or take a few now
that's quite impressive considering the
fact that Apple has been the leaders in
light thin powerful laptops for almost a
decade now
whereas Microsoft has just come into the
game and they're absolutely killing it
with this product sticking to the
externals of this laptop on the side
you're going to notice that it has a
proprietary Microsoft charging point
this is actually one of my key
disappointing features of this laptop it
does not have USB C at the moment if I
had USB C it would be a lot more
future-proof in my opinion however all
that were left with really is one single
USB port on the side and Thunderbolt
port as well we also do have a headphone
jack which is fantastic they haven't
gone ahead and removed it like every
other company started with their mobile
phones but we are left with only one USB
I guess this note is a little bit unique
to me and not many people have actually
done this to their service laptops to
geez yeah but within the first couple of
weeks of owning this one I've
accidentally dropped it straight on to
the concrete so the corner here I'm not
sure if you guys gonna be able to tell
on this lens but it has dented the
tiniest bit
however the screen did not shatter I've
had service products in the past where
I've accidentally dropped them or
knocked them and the screen has
absolutely shattered into a million
pieces
thankfully hand on heart this one did
not break and it was fantastic news for
me because the screen replacements are
about $1000 and that's not something you
want to pay when you've already spent
$3,000 one laptop moving forward after
you've set up this laptop and you're
using it on day to day basis you're
actually going to be pleasantly
surprised by the fast load time it
incorporates a brand new windows face
recognition software and unlike any
other computer I've used in the past
including other surface devices it's
actually lightning fast now this is
something that's gonna please you
diehard gamers
out there the keyboard on this product
is actually incredible for something
with a very sleek modern design it
actually has quite a lot of travel in
the keys you're going to notice that you
can hear the keys typing away something
that a lot of people have been
complaining about this product here on
the internet on YouTube in particular is
actually the screen brightness however I
haven't had any issues with this product
I've used it all around the world in
different lighting situations in bright
lights like in the studio and even
outside in direct sunlight I haven't had
an issue to date unlike in the past
where I've owned the generic surfaces
themselves with the little flippy flimsy
keyboard their screens are actually
incredibly hard to deal with in the
harsh sunlight conditions there was one
day where I was sitting next to my
partner on my surface and she had her
macbook out and it was night and day she
could see everything perfectly clear and
I was really struggling to see my
content on the computer okay so this is
a feature which may or may not interest
you personally to me it made absolutely
no difference what the speakers sound
like on this machine however if you're a
video editor in 2019 chances are you
might want the speakers to be crisp and
clear when you don't have your
headphones laying around and you're
doing some video editing on the fly now
pulled up one of my old videos here and
set the volume for about 50% I maybe I
made out a meter and half away from the
camera and I'm going to hold it from
this distance and again closer to the
camera so you guys can get a clearer
understanding of what the speakers are
like how powerful they are and how clear
they are what's going on guys my name is
anna scott mitchen welcome back to the
channel and they have it the speakers in
this device actually quite good from a
little small device that weighs less
than a MacBook Air it is actually
incredible what they've been able to
produce the sound does kind of seem to
come through the keys as there isn't too
many open holes and ports on the device
but that isn't a deal-breaker at all one
fault that I had found in this laptop
and with actually most new products on
the market is the fact that gets very
hot very quickly especially when running
programs like Premiere Pro or Photoshop
or even after
one thing that did surprise me is it
gets very hot and very loud when casting
over your chromecast so when you're
streaming a movie on YouTube on to your
TV for some reason the computer can't
really handle it the programs don't talk
well to each other and the fan just
keeps on to maximum straight away I did
a test the other day and streamed a 40
minute video from my laptop to micro
class in the living room and the battery
dropped from a hundred percent down to
76 percent that's 24 percent in 40
minutes
now considering this laptop is meant to
have a 14 and a half hour battery time
24 percent in 40 minutes is very
disappointing how about a general
day-to-day basis I did get about 6 or 7
hours out of this laptop without having
to worry about charging it throughout
the day
I have never to this day got 14 and a
half hours and I'd be impressed if you
could get 14 and a half hours especially
considering it says with genuine video
content viewing something that is a bit
of a nice touch and something that was a
little bit worried about when purchasing
this laptop was an app enteric keyboard
the keyboard is a nice soft suede kind
of finish and it's really nice to type
on on a day to day basis I always
thought that the general sweat marks and
heats of your hand would leave stains on
this keyboard
however with 7 months of using this
product there isn't a single mark on it
and it is a fantastic sign for me so
what's the verdict should you go out and
buy this laptop hands down straight away
throw all your money away should you
wait a couple months or should you
completely avoid it well I've been doing
my research and as always Microsoft
tends to release new products later on
in the year we are expecting to see a
brand new surface laptop product late
2019 somewhere in the october/november
period now if you're not desperate for a
new laptop I would personally recommend
waiting because chances are this new
laptop is going to come out with a USB C
port and like I said USB C is the future
so this laptop would be a lot more
future proof whereas this one here at
the surface laptop 2 will become
obsolete in three four years when
everything's moved to USB C if you are
in the market for a brand new laptop
today then hands down
would recommend the surface laptop - it
has been a great device for general
day-to-day work and even video
production and movie editing and running
three companies simultaneously it is
however at the top of the range surface
laptop - and I don't have any experience
with the lower end of the product range
however I do believe that all of them
will be quite good and you shouldn't
have too many problems regardless of the
model that you select and then have it
guys that's my personal opinion on my
seven-month-old day-to-day run and gun
laptop if you liked this video make sure
you smash that subscribe button
20-19 style give it a like maybe drop a
comment and let me know your thoughts
and like always I'll see you next Monday